♪♪
[ Stopwatch beeps ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I have been told a Negroni
is not a Negroni
unless it has an orange slice.
So I ordered one.
Not sure if it will make it here
before the end of "Corrections."
I am confused
about something.
I read the "Correction"
comments every week,
and people often will ask
questions that have been
answered within the body
of a previous "Corrections."
People will say,
"What is he drinking?"
I've said Negroni
in multiple "Corrections."
How are you not watching
all of these?
[ Laughter ]
Like, it doesn't work if you
don't watch all of these.
"Do you watch
'Game of Thrones'?"
"Well, I catch it when it's on."
What?
[ Laughter ]
You got to watch all of these.
So many of the questions --
What am I drinking?
A Negroni.
"Did you know Doug Jones was
the original Mac Tonight?"
I do.
Why are shows --
Why is "Closer Look"
not on in Canada anymore?
Because you're bad listeners.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, I was told VHS tapes
don't play backwards
if you put them
in upside down.
[ Laughter ]
Agree to disagree.
Last week,
I called out Sal Gentile
and said he was wrong
in his interpretation
of the landmark Supreme Court
case Marbury v. Madison.
Sal was right, it turns out.
But by calling him
out in "Corrections,"
I did inadvertently get Sal
into the Guinness Book
of World's Records
for "Longest Mutter."
[ Laughter ]
[ Muttering ] Huh?
What are you talkin' about?
[ Muttering indistinctly ]
Really had to talk Sal off --
He wanted to write
a "Closer Look"
about YouTube commenters.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about
Scooby-Doo last week
and how he said "Ruh-ro."
I was told by many of you
Astro from "The Jetsons"
was the originator of "Ruh-ro."
Interesting fact here.
The actor who did Astro would
later go on to voice Scooby-Doo.
And that must have been a very
weird call from his agent.
He's like, "Hey, baby, I got you
the lead in a new pilot,"
and he's like,
"Oh, that's great.
Anything as long as I'm not
doing another cartoon dog,
if you know what I mean."
[ Laughter ]
"You still there?"
"Ruh-ro."
This is a correction
I had a hard time
wrapping my head around.
Correction --
Scooby-Doo isn't a dog.
In later seasons, it established
that Scooby is actually
an alien known as an Anunnaki,
a race of ancient creatures
that can cross universes
and take over
the form of animals.
I'm not sure what season
that plot point was established,
but I'm...
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna guess the last one.
"Ratings are down.
Should we throw this [bleep]
Hail Mary?"
[ Laughter ]
"Kids like space, right?"
Last week, I addressed
one of you said
my Shaggy impression
sounded like Werner Herzog.
I put that to bed.
But then one of you
this week said,
when you heard me say my Shaggy
sounded like Werner Herzog,
you thought it was
the singer Shaggy.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Werner Herzog ]
It wasn't me.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, you caught me
on ze counter.
[ Laughter ]
It wasn't me.
I believe you believe
you saw me
banging on the sofa.
[ Laughter ]
But it wasn't me.
[ Normal voice ] A lot of you
said Jacob Marley is a ghost.
The other three are spirits.
Can you really tell
the difference between a spirit
and a ghost?
I know you can tell
the difference between a spirit
and a JetBlue.
[ Laughter ]
Baze, I did it
just like you said.
[ Laughter ]
"Then lean forward
like you're proud of it."
[ Laughter ]
It's Thanksgiving,
not April Fools, Baze.
[ Laughter ]
Um...
You know, there's a --
We've been talking about Devon,
the 28-year-old teenager
who turns up a lot on our show.
He turned up twice in a week,
and then one of you said,
"I think he --
I think you've used him
more than just a few times."
And, you know,
there's this consensus...
building that young people
don't like to work anymore.
But let me tell you
something about this kid.
Does a shift at DQ...
then he goes over
to Burger King...
then he goes to Chipotle...
[ Laughter ]
...then he
heads over to Kinko's.
Yeah, sure.
Then he toilet-papers my house.
But next morning,
he's at the amusement park.
Then it's off
to Dunkin' Donuts...
Best Buy...
then he breaks
his [bleep] leg...
[ Laughter ]
...and then,
it's over to 7-Eleven.
Thank you for your work, Devon.
[ Laughter ]
Someone, uh --
Someone wrote this comment --
"This show sucks.
He must be paying
that phony audience to laugh.
Sounds like about 10 people,
LOL."
[ Laughter ]
First of all, dude...
...it used to be 10, but then
we let the interns start coming,
and it's 16.
[ Laughter ]
I was actually worried
our audience
would be a little thin today
because, you know,
a lot of our crew
has left to get to the airport
for the holiday.
We have a diverse crew from
all over the country,
everywhere from
the top of New Jersey
to the middle of Long Island.
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
Thank you.
Ah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, honey?"
"What?"
"You know how you say I'm never
gonna sell my old cans on eBay?"
[ Laughter ]
"Well, I just sold one
to a talk-show host."
[ Laughter ]
"My ship came in, baby!"
$6, plus shipping.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, we just mentioned
New Jersey.
We mentioned Trump looked like
a tiger in a podunk zoo
in Central New Jersey.
A lot of you got mad.
You said it's either
Northern New Jersey
or Southern new Jersey.
I was purposefully vague
about where in New Jersey
this podunk zoo was,
because the last thing I wanted
was some actual Jersey zookeeper
taking offense.
You know, I don't need
one of them
waiting outside the building
when I walk out, and he's like,
"Who's podunk now?"
and throws a bunch
of salamanders on me.
[ Laughter ]
Two years ago, I announced
the birth of our daughter
on Thanksgiving "Corrections,"
and I told the story about
how her first name is Adelaide,
which is my grandmother's name
and why that was such
an important name for us.
And I forgot to mention
that her middle name is Ruth,
which is my wife's
grandmother's name.
And then I showed
on Thanksgiving.
I showed the "Corrections"
to my family and and my in-laws.
And my wife took me
aside afterwards to go,
"I think it really
hurt my feelings
that you would forget
to say the Ruth part."
And I was like,
"Oh, my God, I'm so sorry.
It just slipped my mind."
And so last year's "Corrections"
on Thanksgiving,
I corrected the record, and I
said her middle name was Ruth.
And I told that story
independently.
And then I told her,
assuming she would say,
"Good job. You fixed it,"
but instead she said, "I don't
think people pay attention.
I think they only pay
attention the first time.
And I think -- I think
they pay attention.
I think everybody knows now
her name's Adelaide Ruth,
and we can just
put it behind us."
True story -- the other day,
my oldest son said to the Alexa,
"Alexa, what are
Seth Meyers' kids' names?"
and Alexa said,
"Seth Meyers has three children.
Their names
are Ashe Olson Meyers,
Axel Strahl Meyers,
Adelaide Meyers."
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "Alexa,
how do you not know that?"
And she said, "I don't
watch every 'Corrections.'"
[ Laughter ]
Security guard John O'Malley
won the "Corrections" pool
last week.
Wasn't even here.
[ Laughter ]
So the saddest thing happened,
which is Jim had to call
and give him the good news.
[ Laughter ]
Poor Jim had to deliver it to --
O'Malley, who wins this thing,
I feel like, every other week.
O'Malley's walking out of here
with a handful of cash.
[ Laughter ]
Still surprised every time
he wins.
'Cause I saw him on Monday,
I was like, "Congratulations."
"I couldn't believe it, Seth."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I mean..."
[ Laughter continues ]
"...I'm sitting at home,
I get a phone call from Jim.
I'm like,
'Is there an emergency?'
So, I pick up the phone.
Jim gives me the news.
I'm excited. Jim's excited.
Yeah, I was over the moon."
[ Laughter ]
"I mean, I'm winning
at this pool,
so I feel like I'm as good
at pools
as my daughter Katie is
at field hockey."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
John is very proud
of his children.
[ Laughter ]
I am certain that if John is
ever on duty
when I'm attacked...
[ Laughter ]
...the assailant will get by
because he will be showing
a picture of one of his children
to a stranger on his phone.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, we did our 50th
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell"
on Tuesday.
Jenny and Amber surprised me.
They changed the format
to celebrate the 50th.
A lot of jackals
asked questions about this.
One was,
"Was Seth really surprised?"
I definitely
was really surprised.
Next question was,
"Was he really angry?"
I was not really angry,
but I did feel, for the purposes
of the comedy,
I should play as though
I was a little bit angry
that they had pulled
one over on me,
which they had
effectively done.
I wasn't angry
because I felt safe,
because Amber and Jenny
are very kind, very empathetic
comedy writers, and I knew
that they would not --
they would go
right up to the line
without actually crossing it
and putting me in a situation
where I could get myself
in trouble.
So that was
the nice part about it.
Now, if there was
a surprise sketch
where I found out in real time
that Mike Scollins
had written stuff...
[ Laughter ]
...that I had to read on --
I would know
my career is over.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Werner Herzog ]
It was me.
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to keep up
this charade any more.
[ Laughter ]
You even caught me on camera.
I blame myself.
How could I forget
I'd given you the extra key?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Well...
[ Laughter ]
I, uh -- I --
Happy Thanksgiving, everybody.
This is genuinely such a special
part of the week for me.
And I really like that
you're here for this every week.
I really like that I get to be
here and do this every week.
It's a very special thing
to share with my crew.
It's extra special tonight
because there are people here
[voice breaking] who mean a
great deal to me
that aren't always here,
and they know who they are.
[ Sniffles ]
And, uh...
[ Laughter ]
[ Sniffles ]
Well...
[ Stopwatch beeps ]
Kenny won.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Or at least you would have
if it was over now.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Will the show pay for this?
[ Laughter ]
See me next two weeks.